- I look like Helga
from Hey Arnold!
(bell chiming)
(whooshing, sign squeaking)
- Today we're gonna be
trying the squiggle brow.
- I have heard of the squiggle brow.
I've also heard of the squiggle lip.
People just really like
squiggly things right now.
- No one's actually doing this for real.
Like you're not stepping out
into the world like this.
- I can't even be mad at it.
It's a well-made brow.
- [Kayleigh] It's like an ocean
over the top of your eyes.
- I do fill in my brows.
- I generally just don't
do make up in general.
- It's better than the
feather brow, for sure.
- I only want a squiggle at the end.
And I think what I'm gonna do is
just like dip into my natural brow
and start the squiggle process.
- So in terms of confidence
right now I'm at a solid four.
- Can I just cover my
entire brow with concealer?
- Squiggle with it,
squiggle with it, okay.
- The eye pencil I'm
using is called Corrupt,
and I am corrupting my face right now.
- I'm drawing my squiggle.
If I'm going big, I'm going ho--
Wait, that's not how the saying goes.
- Don't do concealer first.
I think I have more like zig-zag.
- Maybe that's gonna be
the new trend after this.
The zig-zag brow.
- This squiggle is about to be
off the motherfucking chain.
- Do you think people are
gonna react positively?
- They're gonna send me home.
- For looking too good.
It looks like I have little toupees
floating over my eyes right now.
- Art defined, pow.
(laughing)
(camera clicking)
- I think it's time for us
to show these looks off.
- Um, you know, interesting.
- Yeah, it's better than what
I've seen on the internet.
- Thanks.
- Oh, okay.
- Thank you so much.
- Look at you from the sides.
I don't know, you just look
really upset about something.
- I'm worried why you're
covering your face,
so I'll start over here.
- This one's just thick.
- I would pass on the said squiggle brow.
- But yours, they don't look too bad.
- Thank you.
- Yours looks more like the Joker.
- He's a popular character.
I fit into pop culture now.
- It looks a little different.
- Looks like something went wrong.
- I'm one-brow Dee today.
- I still don't see a squiggle.
- We're walking down the
streets of New York City.
- I would have to say thumbs down.
- It's different.
- [Anita] Different good, different bad?
- Just different.
- You wanna do some crazy
shit with your eyebrows,
you should come to New York.
- Like does anyone see a squiggle here?
- No.
(laughing)
- I'd say the reactions have been
more positive for Sasha.
- I learned that you shouldn't
use a gray eyeliner pencil
to fill in your eyebrows.
- No one's gonna insult us
to our faces, I don't think.
- Let's roll the camera back.
- Looks like you're going to the circus.
- From the responses that
we've gotten around the office,
I low-key look cute.
- I would do the squiggle brow
for maybe Halloween, a rave.
- I give the squiggle brow a
thumbs up if you do it right.
- The thing to learn here is subtlety.
My look, a little over the top.
- So I'm all for the idea.
Great idea, horrible execution.
- Squiggle brow, like up in the
club with the LED eyelashes.
- What clubs are you going to?
- I'm not a professional,
but I wanted to try it
to show the other people out there
who don't do their own makeup
that they also shouldn't do it
and that they should
have somebody with them
who knows how to do their brows help them.
You'll get better results,
as opposed to this.
(rock music)
(sign whooshing, squeaking)